with the Microsoft translator extension
you can now translate webpages from over
50 different languages to your language
of choice with the simple click of a
button making web content from around
the world even more accessible to you on
Microsoft edge first go to a website
written in a Microsoft translator
supported language for this example we
will use MSN Spanish as the page loads
you will see the translator icon show up
in the address bar
now click on translate the web page will
be translated to your language
you can also select some text right
click and select translate in the
context menu to get a translation for
the selected text if you need to change
any additional language settings you can
simply go into options and change your
preferences
thanks for watching